une réplique de magnitude de 7,5 a été
ressenti en Turquie et en Syrie après un
premier tremblement de terre très
violent survenu dans la nuit là-bas le
bilan provisoire dépasse les 1500 morts
et ça continue de se leur dire nous
allons retrouver une de nos collègues
une collègue de CBC qui dahlia ashri qui
se trouve d'ailleurs à gaziane tape j'en
parlais à l'instant d'un château qui
s'était écroulé vous êtes dans le sud de
la Turquie dites-nous dahlia pouvez-vous
nous décrire un peu ce que ce que vous
avez vécu comment vous avez ressenti
cette ce tremblement de terre
il y a beaucoup de choses qui se passent
ça ici des quatre heures dans le matin
aujourd'hui j'ai décidé d'aller dehors
et marcher voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
et quand vous avez dit le château il y
avait beaucoup de roches qui sont
tombées mais aussi les électrices il y a
beaucoup de roches des édifices qui sont
tombés quand vous avez déjà dit beaucoup
de gens qui sont morts et en train de
faire la recherche pour les autres ici
derrière moi après le deuxième
tremblement de terre il y a beaucoup de
roches qui sont tombées mais parce que
l'hôtel que je suis maintenant c'est
vraiment vieux alors et ces cours c'est
pas vraiment les défis qui est long
alors c'est pour ça que c'est il y a
l'assurance ici pour moi mais quand même
c'était quelque chose vraiment effrayant
pour pas seulement moi mais les autres
aussi beaucoup des gens vacués des
édifices ils sont dehors ils essayent
d'avoir de l'eau alors il y a des
endroits où peuvent avoir l'eau et puis
aussi il y a des gens qui s'assoient
dans leur véhicule pour avoir le chaud
dans leur véhicule et ça c'est un
problème aussi parce qu'il n'y a pas de
gaslit dans leur véhicule parce qu'ils
s'assoit tout le journées dans leur
véhicule alors c'est vraiment une
événement difficile bon comment
avez-vous été réveillé est-ce que
c'était très très fort comme tremblement
de terre il y avait pas d'autres vous le
saviez que c'est un tremblement de terre
comme l'ensemble de la population
oui c'était vraiment forte c'est pas
toujours quand je me réveille avec une
tremblement de terre alors c'était 4h
dans le matin j'étais en train de dormir
et mon lit est a commencé de se trembler
et puis j'ai pensé à ce que je me à ce
que je me rêve ou c'est la vérité mais
c'était vrai il y avait le tremblement
et puis j'ai décidé de faire ce que je
dois faire je peux pas aller sous un
table parce qu'il y a un miroir alors ça
peut tomber sur moi alors oui alors les
gens m'ont venu dans l'hôtel et ils
m'ont dit que tu dois marcher du lit et
aller dans le lobby ils m'ont donné
l'eau et nous ils ont dit de rester ici
parce que c'est pas vraiment une bonne
situation d'aller dehors parce que comme
j'ai dit il y a des choses ici qui sont
vraiment vieux mais parce que c'est
mon plus bon que les autres défis bon
alors
vous des informations vous voyez vous
les secours venir en aide à ceux qui à
ceux qui seraient peut-être dans les
décombres sous les sous les briques et
sous et sous le ciment et tout ça est-ce
que vous entendez les secours
oui j'entends les secours j'entends le
bruit et c'est vraiment quelque chose
parce que je suis dans une environnement
et si comme vous pouvez voir c'est
vraiment
croise
oui c'est vraiment fermé c'est ça et ils
m'ont dit de rester ici mes grands je
suis allé dehors et aussi pour je veux
dire que le climat aujourd'hui c'est pas
bon il y a
plu il y a le neige alors ça fait
beaucoup le situation plus difficile
pour les gens et je pense aussi pour les
polices et les gens qui aiment essayer
de sauver les gens qui sont aussi dans
le les édifices et essaie de le prendre
j'ai entendu qu'il va avec leur main et
prend les gens alors c'est vraiment il y
a beaucoup d'émotions et je pense aussi
c'est plus difficile pas plus difficile
mais précisément pour les gens qui sont
des séries il vit ici il y a une
population qui s'est vraiment là parce
que le réfugié j'ai parlé avec quelques
gens que je travaille avec et ils m'ont
dit c'est vraiment difficile de sa femme
même en gardien fait ici leur famille
sont bien ou en série aussi alors
beaucoup beaucoup d'émotions je pense
les gens sont effrayés et on a déjà
comme j'ai dit deuxième tremblement de
terre alors je sais pas s'il va y avoir
une autre maintenant en tout cas restez
dans un endroit sécuritaire comme ça je
comprends que ça doit être très
angoissant vivre ces situations là on
veut pas être à votre place
et oui l'Internet
pas d'internet et aussi le chauffage
parce que l'électricité c'est il y a des
moments que j'en ai l'électricité il y a
des moments que j'en ai pas alors il y a
c'est pour ça que je porte mes choses le
passeport
tout est sur vous bon mais tant mieux on
est content de savoir que vous avez pris
les bons moyens c'est ce qu'on appelle
une zone hostile quand on se retrouve
dans ces contextes derrière merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de nous
parler ce matin on vous dit bonne chance
et bon courage merci au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI